ça peut du coup y est conviviale comme
des cartes illustrées ça peut être des
photos ça peut être aussi des couilles
administrative des recommandés etc
vous allez valider votre courrier en
ligne et nous le jour même on râle
imprimés et le poster depuis le début du
confinement on a environ multiplication
par six de nos volumes d'envoi on a eu
au tout début du confinement énormément
de d'envoi de professionnels qui se
retrouvaient jour au lendemain en
télétravail qui était un petit peu
désemparé avec aussi beaucoup de deux
choses du point de vue administratif à
le gérer en urgence donc on a eu une
énorme augmentation de volume des
professionnels au début du confinement
ensuite ça s'est un peu stabilisé et par
contre le les envois de cartes des
particuliers lui se maintient un très
haut niveau
parce que les gens évidemment manque de
contact beau coup d'envoi aussi vers les
ehpad vers les verts des personnes âgées
et sert à ça on le constate vraiment une
très très forte hausse à ce niveau là